ici un tableau là une mosaïque tient une
sculpture se sont en tout soixante
oeuvres d'artistes locaux qui sont
disséminés dans le centre ville quand la
revient au plus près des habitants
la photo a été prise sur une grande roue
à la foire du trône à paris et j'avais
plusieurs photos avec des hauteurs
différentes
j'aimerais interpréter la photo j'ai
redessiné géré a interprété la photo
pour lui pour utiliser les ombrages et
et les pelles et la ville au dos de
personnages pour moi la ii doit aller
doit aller peut s'exposer partout en fin
de compte un pourquoi pas une
cordonnerie c'est un artisan le peindre
c'est un artisan voilà c'est des métiers
qui se rejoint l'initiative est
bienvenue dans un centre-ville plutôt
triste on cette période de fêtes où
beaucoup de boutiques ne sont pas décoré
mais les commerçants ont bien joué le
jeu de faire redécouvrir et découvre
découvrir et redécouvrir notre ville qui
a été sinistrée au mois de mai suite aux
inondations et justement vous avez
beaucoup de commerces qui ont été
fermées des vitres des commerces qui
sont toujours fermés d'ailleurs en
travaux et justement ça permet de
découvrir et redécouvrir nos jolies
notes jolie ville pour l'association
marché s'élève à l'origine de ce projet
ce n'est que du positif pour tout le
monde ce sont tous des artistes locaux
montargois et aux alentours de montargis
des artistes amateurs des artistes
professionnels
donc l'idée c'est un peu de promouvoir
l'art de démocratiser l'art au coeur du
centre ville
et puis amener la culture et l'art dans
un centre ville qui a un petit peu du
mal à à à renaître
c'est important c'est important parce
que l'art va amener un autre public va
faire revenir les gens dans le
centre-ville
une fois que vous avez trouvé à toutes
les oeuvres il vous faut encore mettre
la main sur le graal de votre quête ou
plutôt le père noël bien caché dans une
boutique avant que votre bulletin de jeu
soit peut-être tirés au sort